the goal of this video is to essentially
write down all the numbers in order from
zero to a hundred but I'm gonna do it in
an interesting way in a way that maybe
will allow us to see some patterns in
the numbers themselves so let me just
start so I'm gonna start at zero one two
three four five six seven eight and nine
and instead I don't we know of course
that the next number is 10 which I could
write down but instead of doing that I'm
just going to copy and paste all of this
so copy and paste
all of that and see what this does for
us so if I do that how does that help us
well we know the next number is 10 which
one way to think about it is it's a 1
followed by a 0 what's the number after
that what's 11 which is a 1 followed by
1 what's the number after that was 12
which is a 1 followed by a 2 and then 13
14 15 16 17 18 and 19 well that was
pretty neat this next row of numbers as
I went from 10 to 19 look just like the
first ones so the second number is the
same in yellow but then I added a purple
one to the front of it and one way to
think about it is each of these numbers
do the purple one that I added that
represents 10 so 11 could be viewed as
10 plus 1 12 could be viewed as 10 plus
2 let's see if this keeps working so
let's take another row of numbers so
let's take another row my original row
and what do I get two after 19 well of
course after 19 we get to 20 so 22 zero
and then 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 I
think you might start to see the pattern
here what are we gonna do for the next
row well now we're in the 30s so the
first number 30 is 30
plus zero 30 plus 130 plus 2 30 plus 3
which is 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 so just
doing that I think you already see the
pattern the the number on the right we
keep going from 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and
then the number on the left if we're in
the 10 if we're between 10 and 19 you
always have a 1 if you're between 20 and
29 you always have a 2 here between 30
and 39 you always have a 3 now how can
how could I complete this going all the
way to 99 and a pretty fast well let's
just do that so that's going to be my
40s I haven't written it out yet that's
going to be my 50s this is going to be
my 60s 60s 70s 80s 80s and then I have
my 90s right over here and so this one
we already said this is going to be my
40s this is going to be my 50s this is
going to be I'm trying to make sure I
use all my colors my sixties this is
going to be my 70s and then I have my
80s and then of course I have I have my
my let me do a color that well I'll
reuse the magenta I have my 90s so what
if I were to just take this so let me
just take this right over here and copy
and paste that so copy and then let me
paste it so now I have 41 51 61 71 81
and 91 now I can do it over here 42 50
to 60 to 70 to 82 and 92 and I can do it
for each of these for each of these now
so that's now 40 450 460 470 480 494 and
so when I do that we see the full
pattern we see the full pattern and I'm
almost done I'm almost done filling in
my numbers from zero to
ninety nine forty nine fifty-nine sixty
nine seventy nine eighty nine ninety
nine and if we just want to feel good we
could throw in we could throw in a
hundred a hundred right right over there
and you see that the pattern still holds
we went from one two three four five six
seven eight nine and now we got two ten
followed by a zero that was pretty neat